ces conventions
merci merci
je ne n'ai pas encore mériter ça va
venir que sera ce que j'aurais parlé oui
alors jean bienvenue à bord bienvenue
dans ton village à bourgueil tout le
monde était viticulteur même ton père
qui était brellier oui oui enfin tout le
monde avait son petit pied de vigne
s'était pas encore une période où la
ville était aussi maintenant c'était
sont de grandes propriétés maintenant il
n'y a plus beaucoup de petits
viticulteurs quoique se connaissent dans
certains coins des gens qui font une
barrique de vin par an ils sont 11 mai
10 20 absolument extraordinaire des gens
qui font du vin pour leur plaisir et
dans le goût est totalement leur fait de
leur coeur de leur passion delà de leur
passion de la vie et de la grappe qui
font du vin quand tu es complètement
sincère et et qui ne suivent aucune mode
que la mode de leur goût tu vas être un
grand connaisseur du poids du non non
non je vous tiendrais mais je peux
goûter mais je sais que vous m'avez gare
tgv l'étiquette
ça c'est superbe saclay sans faute ouais
c'est superbe une grande année c'est
peut-être même un petit peu de jeunes
c'est un 80,2 dans trois ou quatre ans
aura pris son ampleur total tenait
surgir lassana sahraouis mais rien
n'aurait on sera encore là aussi pensent
bien oui parce que j'espère bien mettre
même être la plus plus tard parce que le
89 et 90 sont splendides falloir les
voir dans dix ans le vin c'est une
question
d'émotion de l'instant commandes il ya
des vins me voir et ça par exemple le
matin sur une bonne tartine de
20 du matin non ça c'est pas rien je
boirai un petit vin chemin de la loire
un petit vin amusant ferait un vin un
vin qui réveille qui qui respirent les
senteurs qui sont un peu la mousse qui
sont toutes les humidité du matin et
puis après mon banc dans la journée ça
c'est un vin à boire bon peut-être à
table bien sûr mais peut-être à boire
avec un copain comme ça dans un après
midi de tête à tête où on va dire des
choses oui ou des choses intelligentes
ou complètement contre fait rien enfin
qu on va boire comme ça un moment que le
vin est bon les yeux dans les yeux et
c'est ça en parlant de copains ton ami
depardieu oui nous on le connaît comme
acteur mais comme viticulteur qui se
débrouille mais c'est pas ils se
débrouillent pas c'est devenu un grand
viticulteur il a appris il a appris la
vigne contact même de la vigne en y
mettant son coeur et il a envie il a eu
envie de le faire il y est arrivé et
s'est il le fait avec une recherche
profonde avec un goût il ne fait pas un
vin qui est un vin de qui est un vin de
charme absolu il fait pas un vin
fabriqué il fait un vin qui a une
véritable marche sur 20 qui vous
laissent quelque chose dans dans la
bouche au premier contact qui
quelquefois n'a pas un est terrible
parce que le nez et souvent trompeur
mais c'est un vin qui est un joli retour
une unv un politique est vrai dont on
mord dans quelque chose on est à la
maison la grappe congo au mordant de
terroir et puis c'est une religion le
vin c'est pas une religion c'est une
chose c'est comme les filles c'est comme
tout ce qui est bon à regarder voir
c'est comme un beau coucher de soleil
comme une belle lune
il dit moi je n'ai pas de partir il
s'appelle jeanne aux petits bras pour
voir parce que j'ai les bras courts bon
avant ah oui je les bras regarder avec
ses meubles et là encore on fait des
manches sur mesure encore ça se voit pas
trop où ça ne touche pas l'infirmité
mais j'ai pas il m'appelle aussi les
petites jambes agent m'appelle aussi les
petites jambes parce qu'il a des grandes
jambes lui d'ailleurs je trouve je le
trouve totalement anormal physique qui
compte dans la vie mesure plus d'un
mètre 65 mais a priori suspecte non
c'est vrai que dans ta maison dans le
gard la cour fait caisse de résonance et
canton voisin votre invité il débouche
une bouteille comme ça se fait pas mais
ce soit pour lui dire que tu acceptes tu
réponds quoi j'arrive
entendre bouchons
tu te balades toujours avec avec un tire
bouchon soit toi j'ai un tire bouchon
sur moi malheureusement c'est un tire
bouchon de je ne dirais pas de parade
mais ça n'est pas un tire bouchon qui va
très très loin par exemple pour
déboucher cette bouteille là j'aurais
peut-être eu du mal parce que c'est un
tire bouchon a comme ça il n'y a que
c'est c'est une fête un tire-bouchon
hackett ça vous intéresse peut-être
bientôt le 31
et là par exemple pourquoi pour qu'une
bouteille je vois bien déboucher il faut
quand même que le bouchon maintenant il
ya des tire-bouchons fabuleux dont on
fait la publicité qui ouvre la bouteille
comme ça sans
sandales sans dommage pour la bouteille
mais il n'y a pas le bruit mais tu l'as
toujours sur toi tu n'es jamais pris au
dépourvu oui jamais jamais quand
j'oublie je suis malheureux qui montrent
quelque chose pour moi c'est pire que
quand j'oublie mes clés aux mouchoirs un
jour que je suis enrhumé un mouchoir me
démerde intervenir très très dur avec
les doigts
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu